"The Batman" takes place in a brand new version
of Gotham City which is completely different
to the one seen in the DC Extended Universe
features "Batman v Superman," "Justice League,"
and "Birds of Prey."
Matt Reeves' vision for the urban jungle is
very much a grimy, dark place where it always
seems to be raining.
The setting matches the equally moody new
version of Batman, who protects the innocent
from the hordes of criminals who move through
all corners of the city.
When The Riddler starts his war on corruption
within the ranks of Gotham's political, financial,
and law enforcement spheres, Bruce Wayne has
to dive head-first into a sprawling mystery
that stretches from the mayor's office to
the bowels of the seedy Iceberg Lounge.
The Riddler's brutal game reveals some devastating
truths about the city, and it even forces
Bruce to grapple with his family's legacy.
Thomas and Martha Wayne’s memories were
tarnished both in the eyes of the public and
Bruce by the time the credits roll, mainly
due to The Riddler revealing Thomas Wayne
tried to keep the lid on Martha’s mental
illness treatment at Arkham Asylum which ultimately
spiraled out to involving Carmine Falcone
(KAR-mine fal-KOH-nee].”
.
None of this matters to the citizens of Gotham,
who must fight for survival when The Riddler
bombs the sea wall, flooding most of the city.
To make matters worse, the Caped Crusader
has to battle a number of the villain's faithful
followers inside the roof of Gotham Arena
as they try to shoot crowds of survivors.
It's a dramatic final battle that sees Batman
fighting The Riddler's violent ideology, as
embodied by his followers, and the fight nearly
gets the better of him.
But, thankfully, the Bat has a surprising
weapon in his utility belt.
During the fight on the arena's railings,
things go from bad to worse for the Bat when
he ends up on his back after taking numerous
shots from Riddler's followers.
Unfortunately, one of the shooters takes the
opportunity to attack Selina Kyle, who tries
to stop the gang from committing mass murder.
For a moment, it looks like one of them might
kill her, which causes Bruce to pull a small
vial of green liquid out of his utility belt
and inject it.
This green liquid gives Batman a much-needed
adrenaline boost, energizing him to the degree
that he can save Selina and finish the battle
for Gotham's soul.
But that mysterious liquid is never actually
addressed, leaving us to wonder what exactly
the Bat injected.
It's hard not to see it as a nod towards the
classic villain, Bane. DC fans will know that
the muscled behemoth uses a green formula
called "Venom" to give him enhanced strength
and speed in a fight.
It typically gives him a brutal edge over
his opponents, not unlike the burst of ferocious
energy Bruce gets in the final showdown near
the end of "The Batman."
This leaves audiences with a few questions
that we annoyingly don't get the answers to,
including: Has Batman already crossed paths
with Bane?
Or is he out there in the world waiting for
his chance to strike?
Will Bane show up in a sequel to "The Batman,"
should that next movie ever be greenlit?
Probably not.
The green liquid Bruce Wayne uses in the final
fight is not a big enough Easter egg to suggest
the man who broke the Bat is coming to Gotham
anytime soon.
Plus, Matt Reeves has already opened up about
what he'd like to do with a second film if
Warner Bros. gives him the go-ahead -- and
it doesn't sound like the hulking figure is
involved in the director's vision.
In a recent interview with Collider, Reeves
explained that, when it comes to DC characters,
he wants to find the most "grounded" way of
telling their stories.
He went on to say he already has an idea of
how to adapt one of the most iconic villains
in Batman's rogue's gallery: Mr. Freeze.
Plus, after The Riddler is safely in custody,
he speaks with his next-door cellmate, and
while he never mentions a name, it's fairly
obvious this character, played by Barry Keoghan,
is supposed to be the newest version of the
Joker.
So, while this is great news for fans wanting
more from Reeves' contributions to the DCEU,
don't expect to see Bane go up against Robert
Pattinson's version of the Caped Crusader
any time soon.
With the director's "grounded" approach to
comic book storytelling, it probably wouldn't
be a good idea to use Bane anyway, since Christopher
Nolan already delivered a realistic version
of the villain played by Tom Hardy in 2012's
"The Dark Knight Rises."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about “The
Batman” are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.